and Jeffrey stone author of perilous
times that's followed at 2:45 p.m.
Eastern with death in the Haymarket
James green on the 1886 Haymarket
bombing which occurred at a protest over
police brutality during labor unrest in
Chicago and at 3:30 manhunt
James Swanson on the 12 day search for
Lincoln's assassin John Wilkes Booth
now Stephen Kinzer from printers Row
Book Fair in Chicago well thank you and
I welcome you to to the printers Row
Book Fair and and thank you on behalf of
the Chicago Tribune Steve here we've
known each other in fact we met in
Turkey many years ago and he is author
of not only overthrow but several other
books on the Middle East Turkey Iran and
his latest book is really an ambitious
one his skill and evocative storytelling
that sometimes resembles a thriller he
recounts how America over the past 110
years
uprooted and deposed about 14 foreign
governments which to please displeased
America for a variety of ideological
political and economic reasons he's a
the for Americans who wondered why do
they hate us in the aftermath of 9/11
this book should be required reading and
it contains many of the answers to that
question he's the first author to tie
all of these coos together so Steve why
don't you tell us a little bit about how
you got the idea to write this book and
why you wrote it thanks a lot Jim it's
great to be here I'm not used to being
the interviewee I've been in countless
interviews in my life but usually I'm
sitting on the other side so I'll try to
reorient myself I spent a number of
years working in Central America I
covered a war in Nicaragua during the
1980s I also covered the war in
Guatemala that was very intense at that
time
and it was natural that watching those
conflicts so close up and covering them
on a day-to-day basis after a while I
would ask myself why is this happening
why are these countries so poor and why
are they in such conflict the more I
spoke to people and the more I read the
more I realized that certainly in those
two cases of Nicaragua and Guatemala the
long spiral down into chaos and
repression started with an American
intervention later on I went on to write
a book about Nicaragua and I talked
about the history of American
intervention there and I also wrote a
book about the US intervention in
Guatemala so for a while I was pretty
self satisfied I thought that I had
pulled back a little and shown these
countries and the American interventions
that shaped them in a much fuller way
later I did the same thing with Iran I
wrote a book about how the US overthrew
the government of Iran but after a while
I began to conclude that I hadn't pulled
back far enough and that you cannot
really understand modern history or the
20th century history of the United
States or what's happening in the world
today if you look at these American
interventions and these overthrows of
foreign governments as a series of
unrelated episodes only when you see
them all together as a continuum are you
able to tease out certain patterns that
teach us a lot for today so I've told
the story of each of these fourteen
episodes and asked myself three
questions for each one of them the first
is what happened how did we overthrow
the government of this particular
country and the second question is why
why did we do it and the third question
is from the perspective of today from
the perspective of history what has been
the long-term effect of these
interventions and that's the way I've
been able to draw see the similarities
among them and that I think brings us
insights into them and insights into
American history in the modern world
that you don't get when you look at
these operations as
separate unrelated incidents so you say
that the policy of regime regime change
started in Hawaii which is probably not
a place that most Americans would
consider a hotbed of revolution so tell
us what what that was about and can the
actions we took there more than a
hundred years ago have anything to do
with some of the restlessness and
animosity we're hearing about today
actually that was the one I included
because I was hoping to have a long
research assignment work out that way
I'm still waiting for the book tour I
need to visit every every town the
Hawaiian operation was very interesting
because it actually did set some of the
patterns that were followed in future
operations I think probably today most
Americans don't even realize that Hawaii
was once an independent country and as
you say many Native Hawaiians are very
acutely aware of that and that and there
is now a growing what's called a
Hawaiian sovereignty movement which
wants which has the goal in general that
Hawaii should not be treated like all
the other 50 states some would like to
break it away from the u.s. altogether
but many others just feel that it should
have special status and that Native
people with in Hawaii should have
special status and that bill the so
called a Kaka bill is about to be
debated possibly as early as this month
in the US Congress that would give a
series of very special privileges to
Native Hawaiians in kind of compensation
for or recognition of the u.s. role in
Hawaii and in fact when President
Clinton was in office in 1993 the US
Congress passed a resolution officially
apologizing to the people of Hawaii for
the episodes of 100 years earlier
essentially I'm not going to tell you
the whole story and then nobody would
have to buy my book of course but
essentially what happened with it in the
early part of the 19th century several
hundred American missionaries most of
them dour Presbyterians from New England
sailed off to what was then called the
Sandwich Islands with the mission of
raising up the heathen savages as they
would put it and teaching them the
values of Christian civilization it
wasn't long before a number of
these missionaries realized along with
their sons that there was a lot of money
to be made in Hawaii some of them
slipped off the path of God onto the
path of Mammon and by the end of the
19th century a number of them had
accumulated huge sugar plantations they
did this by gobbling up the land that
had been traditionally owned by awayand
families which was not hard to do since
private property is not a strong concept
in traditional Hawaii in any case in the
early 1890s the US Congress passed a
tariff law that made it impossible for
Hawaiian sugar growers to send their
sugar to the US where they've been
selling all their sugar so this
threatened to devastate their fortunes
and they asked them each other what can
we do and they came up with the idea
well the way to send our sugar into the
US would be to just become part of the
US so their leader loren Thurston a
lawyer a white Hawaiian lawyer whose was
the grandson of a missionaries went to
Washington he presented his case to the
President of the United States that
towering figure Benjamin Harrison
President Harrison agreed to support him
he told me you go back to why overthrow
the regime and then we'll take you in so
he went back to Honolulu and then there
formed what amounted to a triumvirate
Thurston himself the leader of the white
Hawaiians the US ambassador who had been
instructed to help this operation in any
way could and then most important the
commander of the u.s. naval ship with
162 Marines that happened to be
conveniently anchored off Honolulu
Harbor so on one day in January of 1893
the white Hawaiian simply called a
meeting and proclaimed the Hawaiian
monarchy is hereby abolished and we are
the new government now and before the
Queen could respond the Ambassador
called ashore from that American warship
150 US Marines they quickly went to
guard the buildings where the Americans
or the white Hawaiians had taken their
offices and that suddenly made it
impossible for the Queen to do anything
because she would have
to fight the US Marines and with that
simple expedient Hawaiian monarchy was
extinguished forever so that did begin
to set some of the patterns that we've
seen in future interventions um
his American policy of regime change
ever produced some positive results of
these coos ever done any good there are
a couple that are exceptions to the rule
in many of these cases we have not only
sent the target country in some cases
whole regions into whirlpools of
instability but we've also created
undreamed of threats that have come back
to haunt us most of these interventions
have been very detrimental to not only
the target countries but also to
American national security in more than
a few cases we have actually overthrown
elected leaders who embraced American
ideals and replace them with tyrants who
despise everything the United States
stands for but there have been
exceptional cases and one I think that
you just mentioned there are plenty of
people in Hawaii particularly in the
Native community who are unhappy with
their situation but by and large
compared to the people who are living in
places like Hawaii or Iran or Iraq or
Afghanistan people in Hawaii are doing
very well they enjoy the prosperity and
the freedom that is your birthright as
an American and compared to the
countries in the neighborhood they might
think that that one came out pretty well
and I think you might even make the same
argument for Puerto Rico also after a
long period of neglect the u.s. finally
began to recognize its responsibilities
in Puerto Rico and if you look at the
countries around Puerto Rico you could
certainly make the case that they're not
doing so badly despite the fact that
there is certainly resistance to
complete assimilation I think the lesson
of those two is that when the United
States actually takes full
responsibility for a place where we've
overthrown the government even if it
takes a long time for us to do that then
we can produce positive results there
but that's really not an option anymore
the more normal case is we overthrow the
government and then as soon as we
achieve our short-term goal of getting
rid of the regime we didn't like then we
turn our back on the place and allow it
to descend into dictatorship or chaos
without caring as long as we don't have
a regime that we feel is challenging us
in many of you your examples you really
draw upon the economic factor that
America is really kind of a errand boy
for big corporations who have these
interests and we go into these countries
and we toss them toss leaders out
because we feel like the economic
interest to these corporations are being
damaged or threatened now as I said your
book is an ambitious one by covering
such a wide sweep of history do you
downplay some of the more political
factors and predict like that in this
book and in the in the Shahs menu in
Iran you say we really were motivated to
topple Mossadegh by oil interest but
weren't there other factors where it
wasn't he and even though it wasn't a
communist didn't he draw support from
the Communist Party and did he anger to
clerics and the bizarre ease and the
others who were also pretty significant
powerful I talked earlier about the way
that studying these operations together
allows you to pick out certain patterns
and one of the patterns that I did
detect as I put these all together has
to do with the question of why why do we
do it now of course not every single one
fits the same pattern but most of them
do and this is the three-part pattern
that I see repeated time and time again
the first thing that happens in these
overthrows of foreign governments is
that the government of some foreign
country bothers or challenges or
harasses or restricts or nationalizes or
regulates some big foreign company
usually an American company if that
doesn't happen if a government in the
country allows American companies to
operate completely as they wish then no
matter what that country sends
the Americans don't focus on it it
doesn't even really come onto our radar
screen as hostile so the first thing
that happens is that there's a conflict
between an American business or a
corporate interest in a country and the
government of that country but the
motivation for the overthrow transforms
when it's in the White House when it's
in the u.s. political process actually
presidents of the United States do not
overthrow foreign governments to protect
the interests of private American
corporations they persuade themselves or
allow themselves to be persuaded that
they are not acting for business or
economic reasons but that they're acting
for what they would call strategic or
geopolitical reasons they conclude that
any government that would try to bother
a restrict or harass or challenge an
American company must by definition be
anti-american and therefore
anti-democratic and repressive and
hostile to freedom and probably the tool
of some great power that is seeking to
undermine US interests all over the
world so sometimes I think that this
debate between whether we do it for
economic reasons or political reasons is
misleading that actually they're the
same reason expressed in different ways
so that's the second phase that the
motivation transforms from the first
phase of economic to the second phase of
say geostrategic but then the third
phase comes when it's time for American
leaders to explain or justify these
operations to Americans and to the world
then they don't use the economic
explanation or the business explanation
and they rarely even say that they're
doing it for political or strategic
reasons that's when the argument is used
we're only doing it to help the people
in that country we are not only not
acting in our own interest but we are
sacrificing ourselves our treasure and
the blood of our young men and women
only to liberate people in other places
that are being brutally oppressed this
is an argument that plays very well in
the United States for two reasons I
think first of all we're very
compassionate people American
I really do hate the idea that
somebody's suffering and miserable and
oppressed somewhere else in the world
and secondly we're naive or innocent or
ignorant enough to believe that we can
change all that just by sending a few
Marines and overthrowing a couple of
guys and that will then produce the
perfect Switzerland where everybody
loves America now I don't think that
people in other countries need to have
this third phase as only Americans that
require this explanation you know for
example as you said I just live in
Turkey the Turks would sometimes send
their army into northern Iraq to chase
anti Turkish guerrillas that had bases
there now that was of course illegal and
when Turks were asked to explain why
they were doing that the Turkish leaders
in the generals saying we're doing this
because it's Turkish interest we're
Turkey we do what's good for Turkey
because no one else will and the Turks
Turkish people seemed fine with that
other countries are the same way when
the French are condemned for what they
do in the South Pacific and their
nuclear tests they always say secular
France it's in France it's interest
we're friends we have to do what's good
for friends and French people think
that's a fine argument but we don't want
to hear that we're the only people I
think in the world that don't want to
believe that we're acting in our own
interest and that's why we are so
vulnerable to this argument we're only
doing it to help the people over there
I'm going to ask one more and then open
it up to the audience so if anybody
wants to ask some questions you can use
the microphones up there but what about
the this you trace kind of the roots of
the whole Islamic terrorism to the coup
in Iran a number of other scholars and
journalists and others say no it
actually goes back much further to the
Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt and it's
expelled and exported the Terrorism
throughout the world why do you focus so
heavily on Iran and what is it about
that movement that you think has been
such a catalyst Iran is really in a very
very positive position very strong
position today they're way stronger than
they were before we intervened in Iraq
fact they're the real winners of the
Iraq war
now this is the first time today
probably since the 30s that no Arab
state exists that has any influence
outside of its own borders but Iran is
the surging power in that part of the
world and Iran has always been one of
the few countries in that region that
has really sought regional dominance
now let's trace very quickly the results
of our coup in 1953 don't forget that
this was a time when Iran was a
democracy it's hard to believe you could
use the word Iran in the word democracy
in the same sentence but that wasn't
always the case
the sin of the most a deque government
was to nationalize the oil industry
which had been in the hands of a foreign
monopoly that set in motion a series of
events that led to most iudex overthrow
in 1953 and that was not just the end of
the must eject government but the end of
democracy forever up to now in Iran now
what were the results we placed the Shah
back on his throne he ruled with
increasing repression for 25 years his
repression produced the explosion of the
late 1970s what we call the Islamic
Revolution that revolution brought to
power a clique of fanatically
anti-american clerics who have spent the
last quarter century intensely and
violently seeking to undermine American
interests all over the world they have
supported all kinds of groups
particularly in the Middle East but also
beyond whose sole aim has been to push
the u.s. out to confront American
influence in that part of the world this
religious regime would never have come
to power would never have inspired
religious fanatics all over the world
including the Taliban and al Qaeda in
next-door Afghanistan if we had not
interrupted the democratic process in
Iran in 1953 this nuclear crisis would
never have emerged in fact we might have
had a functioning democracy a thriving
democracy in the heart of the Muslim
Middle East all these 50
and I can hardly wrap my mind around how
different the middle-east might be today
had we had the patience to do that okay
how about some questions would you state
your name please - this is that just for
mr. Cheney wants to know just in case he
doesn't like it yeah hello I'm Carl
Hayes I just noticed in the last week an
another book about the Pentagon wars
claiming that a lot of the wars since
the Pentagon was built have been
increasingly caused by a a well what did
eisenhower call it the the
military-industrial complex affects I
understand the the draft of that speech
originally had another word in it I
guess it was the Congressional
military-industrial complex but anyway
in in that does that jibe with your
theories or is that separate as early as
lucida geez
political theorists have observed that
countries that have power tend to want
to use it it's just normal that big
powers and big empires don't are not
satisfied just staying within their own
borders in that sense I guess you can
argue that the Pentagon has certainly
been an instrument of American expansion
in American regime change but I would
argue that it's a mistake to focus on
military commanders and secretaries of
defense as the promoters of American
intervention abroad actually in many
cases especially right today you'll find
that the military officers are the ones
most reluctant to get involved in this
they're the ones who know much better
than the amateur weekend warriors and
who are their bosses out what war really
means I also think that it's a mistake
as sometimes was
in the past to look at the CIA as a kind
of an evil agency that runs amok in the
world and does whatever it feels like
this isn't true actually I never found
any case where the CIA did anything
beyond its mandate and what it was
ordered to do by presidents of the
United States under the laws of the
United States and I'll tell you one in
very interesting detail that I found out
while researching this book and I have a
feeling that nobody else has ever
noticed this because you'd have to study
all these for CIA cooze together in
order to notice this the CIA has been
used by the u.s. to overthrow poor
government we overthrew the government
of Iran in 1953 then Guatemala one year
later then the president of South
Vietnam no Jin's ium in 1963 and then I
end a 10 years later in Chile 1973 in
each of these four cases the CIA station
chief in the country the person who we
pay to know more about the inside
workings of a country than anyone else
in our government told us don't do this
this coup is a bad idea it's going to
produce bad results for us it will
undermine our security in the long run
and the answer from Washington in each
of these four cases was thanks for your
report you're fired
we're sending somebody there who doesn't
know anything about the country and he
will then tell us it'll be fine to
launch the intervention so it's not fair
to blame agencies of the government I
find that in these operations they were
all carried out strictly according to US
law and what's a full approval and
direction of the appropriate political
authorities including presidents of the
United States sir yeah well first a
correction and then I would try to large
your theory oh you use expressions like
a place where we have overthrown the
government well I am a pacifist I do not
take two arms I do not identify with
armed action and as an anarchist I have
renounced citizenship declaring myself a
stateless person of the world
I don't overthrow government I think we
should get rid of all of them all which
is not
overthrowing means changing it that was
pre been changing secondly I think a
larger theory is that it is the an
anglo-american was Jewish ruling class
which moves it which has an interest in
ripping off the third world which which
does these things and the question is
sir and oh it is and it is driven by the
Zionist interest especially in the
Middle East so if you want to question
why Avenue what weight do you give to
the Zionist interest and driving all
these schools and overthrows and so
forth okay thank you very much see well
I would like just make a couple of quick
observations you're talking to you refer
to the interest Americans have insert in
the resources of other countries I think
this is very clear one of the main
reasons that we fight and we intervene
and we overthrow governments is the same
reason why people have been countries
have been doing this since forever and
it's the same reason that children fight
in schoolyards one has something and the
other one wants it Americans believe
that we are entitled to a certain share
of the world's resources and we're going
to decide what that share is we often
don't believe that leaders of foreign
countries have the right to cut off our
access to what we feel is our necessary
share of resources just by the fact that
they happen to own the govern the
country where the resource happens to be
and that certainly has driven a number
of American interventions abroad sir
yeah hello my name is Hugh egg L'Arche
and mr. Kinser I have read your book and
I really enjoyed it thank you I had a
couple of questions one thing i was
impressed by was your bibliography which
was very close to comprehensive and
included some very obscure works that
you must have spent some time digging up
i'll just interrupt you for a minute i
had a moment of hesitation when i hit
the send button to send that to my
publisher you know they already told me
when i sent in the first section of my
book it's great but you got a cut of
third they're getting way out of hand
and I realized that this really should
be a 14 volume set that was a little bit
more than my publisher could handle but
one
I was going to send him a 35 pages of
bibliography I was braced for some kind
of a response but they never had they
never had heard a peep and I'm going to
tell them what you said congratulations
thank you anyway I interrupted you go
ahead but there were a couple books that
I didn't notice on the bibliography one
of them was well a couple by William
bloom and also John Perkins his book it
was called something like memoirs about
economic hitman or something like that
and I was kind of wondering what what
you thought about that book and my other
question was one of the again you know I
thought it was a pretty comprehensive
list of regime changes but one thing
that seemed omitted that it that I
thought might be included was the
overthrow of the princi enochian
Cambodia in 1970 and I'm wondering why
that did not qualify actually when I set
out to write this book the first thing I
did was I naturally wanted to get the
list of the countries whose governments
the US had overthrown it was then that I
discovered there is no such list and the
reason is that it's a very subjective
question I realized this when I tried to
put the list together myself where do
you draw the line the US for example was
involved in helping to overthrow
president Sukarno in Indonesia and
president Lumumba in the Congo I don't
include those in my book and for the
same reason that I didn't include the
C&O coup which is that as far as
documents that are publicly available
have been able to show the US was not
the decisive force in that overthrow
that's the phrase that I've used to try
to figure out which book which cools to
include and which to exclude now as I've
been traveling around the country I have
had a number of people stand up or else
tell me privately a great book but you
missed one and then the one they tell me
is always different this is the fact -
the first time I've heard the Cambodian
people have said what about Haiti how
about the Dominican Republic we invaded
the Dominican Republic with our Marines
on the shore
I've had several Greek Americans come to
me and say what about the Colonel's coup
in 1967 most interestingly I had a this
is a wonderful new story this made me
think about some possible future book I
was in Miami in Naples Florida where
there's a
large community of retired foreign
service officers and corporate
executives that have worked all over the
world so although it's a retirement
community it's a very world open and the
guy that was my host was a career CIA
had been a career CIA officer and he was
had been an undercover agent it was
actually out in the field he was a
working as a furniture dealer in North
Africa for a number of years that kind
of thing and he also told me great book
but you missed one and I said Oh which
one
he said Portugal remember when the
Communists the Communists came into
Portugal soon after the end of the
Portuguese Empire Salazar died and so
with my reporters overconfidence and
stupidity really I gave him this little
rap about how well you know we didn't
really do it and you know I've
researched it as not enough material and
took another sip of his drink and then
he said to me I was vice chairman of the
task force so I absorbed just for a
minute I said so did we do it he said
yeah we did it and I said you mean to
tell me but that government of Portugal
that government would not have been
overthrown had not been for us and he
said well maybe some other time some
other way but that coup would not have
happened had it not been for us so that
was the first time again I think hey
maybe I did miss one and I think maybe
I'm just saving that for my my next
project sure hi a quick comment than a
question um we were mentioning about the
CIA earlier on and the inception I
believe in 46 47 after it was the OSS
and prior to that and mentioned also
that maybe four or five give or take
governments were actually overthrown by
the US with help of CIA taking their
orders basically just taking orders but
if you include the amount the number of
countries where the the influence of the
CIA under the tutelage of the government
was used undermine and determine
elections rather than just overthrow him
for instance in 47 the CIA with the
Greek
the the radical labor unions in Greece
and Italy had a huge amount to do the
CIA working sort of you know covertly to
to determine the elections to make sure
that they did not go to the communists
which was a very real scare you're
absolutely correct
the CIA has been involved in a lot of
operations that were covert operations
that greatly affected the political
courses of various countries and that's
the reason why I narrowly defined my
book that's why those don't fit I think
they're fascinating stories let me ask
you this how about putting together what
the CIA did it to influence elections in
France in Italy in Greece after the war
the Portugal coup and maybe a couple of
others we could find and that could be
the book on CIA operations in Europe you
need to that could be can I come back
well actually yeah it's interesting when
I was about 20 years ago I remember
Ralph McGehee Hughes who left the CIA
under protest like a G and a number of
others be after his role of covert
actions and intelligence of CIA during
Vietnam wrote a book that I bought some
time back is at the time on to something
like 135 different cases where the CIA
with the government helped to overthrow
or determine the direction of a
government in 134 135 different
countries and that was 20 years ago so
what I like about these stories what I
find especially interesting about them
is sure they have a great political
lessons for us and the putting them all
together is very provocative for people
that like to think about these things
but there are also such great stories
the kind of writing that I do is very
story oriented I like to tell narratives
I like my books to keep moving I want
people wanting to turn the page all the
time and that's why I've reconstructed
these episodes in a dramatic almost
hour-by-hour basis and that I think in
addition to the fact that I put all
these coos together for the first time
it's the thing that's new in this book
there actually is not much in this book
there are a few facts in this book that
have never appeared in some other book
but nobody ever put all the facts and
accounts together and try to explain how
this coup actually unfolded on a
particular night and what the buildings
look like who the people were what they
were wearing what they did very in a
dramatic sort of cinematic way and
that's one reason I love telling these
stories and I'm so grateful to those
wild characters including CIA agents who
have allowed me to make these story so
interesting my actual question I'm sorry
is just sorry just the the role since
Mossadegh of oil and determining
politics in the Middle East in turn
including what we're seeing now we've
seen a lot of people say well has
nothing to do with what we're doing
right now but what do you say about the
oil politics over the last 40 50 years
middle east I don't think it's realistic
to say that oil does not have a very
important role in American foreign
policy and particularly in our policy
toward the Middle East I think the Iraq
war is unique really in American history
in it being the first war we ever fought
without Americans really knowing why we
fought it even the wars that we were
against we at least knew why they were
being fought in this case I think if you
went out in the street and asked
ordinary people why are we fighting in
Iraq what are we trying to do what are
we trying to get I don't think very many
people would have a good answer I know I
wouldn't and in my book I speculate on
what the reason could have been for the
Iraq operation and the best I could do
was to come up with about ten different
reasons all of which overlap some are
political some are economic some are
psychological but I think the oil factor
is one reason why the u.s. is so focused
on the Middle East I can just remember a
time when I saw the Dalai Lama speak and
somebody got up and asked him what his
reaction was at the time in late 40s
when China gobbled up Tibet and
basically the rest of the world stood by
and thought that was fine didn't want to
do anything and the dalai lama gave one
of those giggles that he's famous for
and then he leaned forward and said so
sad that tibet has no oil
[Laughter]
I think we got time for one more
question go ahead you mentioned my name
is Livingston
you mentioned Hawaii at the beginning
and of course that became a state I was
wondering in your research if you came
across anything that might have shown
how close we've come to making any of
these other countries States or are we
just happy with the round figure of 50
and we don't want to change the flag
anymore it's an interesting question we
actually did think about absorbing
several other places particularly Cuba
actually as early as Thomas Jefferson
Americans were talking about taking over
Cuba there there was a lot of serious
talk towards the end of the 19th century
about us and necks in Canada sometimes I
think if they would have liked the
northern if we'd lost if the South had
won the Civil War in the North they kind
of joined with Canada maybe I would have
made a much more much more responsible
country in the world man now the it's
interesting to note in when you study
the history of how imperialism first
burst out in the u.s. in the late 19th
century the influence that racist ideas
about other countries had in this debate
now it's reasonable very logical to
understand that imperialism in its
original form and one might argue right
up to today has a strong streak of
racism in it not just American
imperialism but also the British and
French and Dutch and Portuguese and
Spanish imperialism also had this idea
that the races were ranked according to
their ability to rule and there were
lower races that were primitive and
barbaric and couldn't govern themselves
and that was why the more advanced white
races had to come in and take over their
countries and run things for them so
that was very logical argument but what
I found more interesting was that in
this debate over whether the US should
take over this big role in the world the
anti-imperialist
also had very had a very
ardan racist argument their argument was
we can't take in Cuba Puerto Rico
Arizona Philippines because we're
getting a lot of non-white people into
the US next thing you know you'll have
the senator Hawaii
the senator from Patagonia the senator
from Cuba or as a one congressman said
Mr Speaker you may even be forced to
call upon with terrifying shiver the
gentleman from the cannibal Islands the
racism played a role on both sides of
this argument and probably still that I
have one more quick question but before
I do I wanted to thank Steve for coming
and thank you ladies and gentlemen on
behalf of the printer's World Book Fair
and the Chicago Tribune and my last
question is can I get you so my book is
one worth thank you very much thank you
[Applause]